i kept on thinking about you know maybe
i have an opportunity
to create alibaba or amazon for india
and that
that thought always haunt me and i kept
on investing more and more time and
effort started more lighting
and eventually i reached to a stage
where i said regret of not doing short
clues
will be bigger than anything i gave up
and i gave up my life in us i gave up a
1 million dollar job
and beautiful house in mission hills in
bay area
and moved to india welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance opposed labs touring
hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
my next guest is the only entrepreneur
to have created two unicorns in india
and he's amazing meet sandeep agarwal
founder of droom and shop clues sundip
is the only indian technology founder
who's created two unicorns back to back
droom india's first online automobile
marketplace
and shop clues india's first ever
managed online marketplace
before his journey into entrepreneurship
he was a former top wall street tech
analyst in the us
who worked with microsoft and charles
schwab during that time he was often
sought as an expert source on tv
networks like cnbc
inside trading charges later dropped
derailed his life
but he fought through the adversity and
never stopped fighting for what he
believes
sandeep agarwal welcome to 20 minute
leaders from new delhi
i am so honored to have you here thank
you for coming
thank you for having me it's such a
pleasure having you today
sandeep the only indian technology
founder who's created two unicorns is
that true
that's right that's right michael i
uh i was in i was in silicon valley
uh uh for most of my ideal life
came to india nine years back uh for my
first venture
and then started the second one six
years back and
both uh became unicorn eventually
unbelievable
simply unbelievable uh droom shop clues
uh
in you know india's first managed online
marketplace and india's first
automobile marketplace i said them in
reverse order
but you know your journey into
entrepreneurship is fascinating i'm
i'm trying to even figure out what i
want to ask you most in these short 20
minutes and i'm gonna decide to opt in
to understand better the indian
ecosystem
what is it like being an entrepreneur in
india building two unicorns marketplaces
in a place that has billion people i'm
so excited
sunday take me through your
entrepreneurial adventure
i want to be there sure absolutely
so uh so michael um while
a lot has changed um in last nine years
since i have been in india
and building drone which is my second
company for last six years plus
uh but uh but let me just share with you
when i came to india in 2011 before that
i was in silicon valley
and to me that time india exactly looked
like
how silicon valley would have been let's
say when
in 1955 1960 when hewlett packard
and xerox were coming up and maybe when
kleiner perkins
was getting formed so you know when i
came to this country
there were uh you know 35 40 million
mobile phone users there were 80 million
internet
there were probably half dozen venture
capitalists there were maybe two dozen
uh angel investors and there were
probably six or eight companies
uh in the internet side and you know
that
the entire market value of all those
companies public and private
probably would be around two billion now
we are talking about
uh you know 800 million on internet most
of them have smartphone
probably there are 200 venture
capitalists who invest in india
there are probably 100 private equity
funds who invest in india
the public and private value of the
entire indian
uh internet sector or i would say vc
funded companies would be more like
200 billion right and probably a dozen
companies have gone ipo
india is home to close to 40 uh unicorn
now
so a lot has changed and evolved uh
right i mean uh you know and i always
used to wonder
will it ever evolve but especially last
three four years
it has evolved in a very rapidly so
you're responsible for five percent of
india's unicorns basically
and just just like that's right i mean
you know when
when show up close when i created shop
clues it was a fifth unicorn
in india and that time it that time it
was more of a novelty
and it was the fastest fastest to reach
billion dollar
in about four years and today i think if
i'm not wrong the fastest is probably
two years
right or less than less than two years
but i'm still very proud
of you know you know creating two uh
unicorn back to back
uh and absolutely long way to go with
doom you know unless we make series of
stupid mistakes
or get unlucky i think it could be a
30-50 billion dollar essay
in next five six years ah i i'm having
so much fun already and it is such an
honor
sandeep what is it like being you know
creating the fifth unicorn in india tell
me a little bit about the indian
ecosystem you decide to go to
automobile marketplace what what what
what what is it
so so um uh
you know uh michael when i moved uh for
my first venture
i actually had i had sourced 1.4 million
uh from my around 10 friends of mine
many of them who studied with me and i
worked on wall street so some of them
were my
client friends i'm so happy right is
around 1.4
so so i raised 1.4 million from them
uh and i was about to move in to india
like i was an indian american and like
me there were three other team members
who lived in who grew up in india but
spent majority of their life in us i
convinced them to come with me
so we all packed our houses sold our
cars
started taking admission for our kids in
india
and i met one of the very famous vc i
will not name
based out of sand hill road and he tells
me that you know why are you raising 1.4
million
you are a famer famous wall street
analyst you are doing this wonderful job
why don't you raise 5 million and we'll
give you that money
i said sure and i made a mistake of not
taking that money
from my friends and just focus on my
venture capital money
and then you know a month later they
gave me a term sheet and they said
congratulations
this term equivalent of getting a
admission letter from harvard university
you have arrived uh and we we you know
we had we were we had our own plan
independent of capital
but you know we were very excited that
very you know a top venture capitalist
gave us so much money
we sold everything we were ready to move
that move back to india
three days before i was going to move
back to india that vc called me and he
said
we are not going to pursue further and
and so
i had already you know sold my every
item i stayed in actually
i stayed in a local hotel for next two
weeks went back to all of my
friends who had given me given me
commitment for 1.4 million
and i i ended up raising 2 million and
and first time
with one-way ticket in 15 years i came
to india
right uh and uh trust me when you know
while i grew up in india i did not spend
15 years here
and i used to come every year like a
tourist but this time when i came with a
one-way ticket
india just sounded so different india
smelled different people look different
and i was very nervous that i'm here for
for a long haul
and for first first six months i would
not
open half of my boxes from us thinking
if the company does not do well i'll go
back
and then you know we got lucky we were
the 35th entrant into indian e-commerce
within six six months we became the
fourth largest
and as i mentioned fourth year a billion
dollar company and then
ended up raising you know 350 million
dollars
from the you know marquee top investors
so so you know but
again you know it was not a it was not a
good it was a quite rough journey in the
beginning
so many vc's said no a lot of uh vcs who
were based out of india they were not
convinced
that i will give up my great life in
silicon valley and a million dollar plus
annual jovan
on wall street to move to india wow i'm
i'm taking a pause because
just wow you know i'm trying to put
myself in your shoes
you know leaving wall street million
million a year to go to india to a place
that what it sounds like
you know you didn't really know what to
expect and it sounds like you you were
you weren't really looking forward to
coming back to
the ex the same place that you had
remembered and coming with that
resilience now walk me through those
first six months where you mentioned
you're climbing from
being the 35th entrant to the e-commerce
world
to becoming the fourth largest that's
really really fast
yeah so yeah so um so michael basically
what happened i was a wall street
analyst in silicon valley
and there was an indian company called
make my trip very similar to booking.com
or expedia
which got listed on nasdaq when they got
listed nasdaq that time e-commerce was
17-year old industry
uh and i and you know for all practical
purpose it was new
so but you know i i had no plan to come
back to india
but i was very fascinated by make my
trip going public
so i decided to launch a research
coverage on make my trip
came to india and i noticed that while
e-commerce was 17 year old industry it
was ready for prime time
after 17 years in india so this was like
united states in 1994.
that's how i thought and so i thought
you know why
why the hell i'm just writing research
report when i create
when i have an opportunity to create an
underlying asset
so so i basically you know it did not
matter how much i ignored
uh but i kept on thinking about you know
maybe i have an opportunity
to create alibaba or amazon for india
and that
that thought always haunt me and i kept
on investing more and more time and
effort started moonlighting
and eventually i reached to a stage
where i said regret of not doing short
clues
will be bigger than anything i gave up
and i gave up my life in us i gave up a
one million dollar job
and beautiful house in mission hills in
bay area uh
and moved to india wow and so two
unicorns
not one in i mean obviously
there's always luck involved i don't
believe luck is is a big factor here it
cannot be
two unicorns back to back what did you
understand
what is it that you understand so
there's one thing that about india being
ready to accept
its own alibaba and its own amazon right
i mean
that there is this opportunity there
what is your deep understanding though
about the indian
culture of working right there is the
famous story of ebay versus alibaba in
the
in the early days what did you
understand about the indian
e-commerce system yeah that made you win
so absolutely
so michael i'm so glad you mentioned
about ebay versus alibaba
so my thesis when i was starting show
clues my thesis was
that india for e-commerce is where u.s
was in 1994
and maybe where you have where china was
in 2004
when each net which was which became
ebay
in china alibaba and zoya which became
amazon
all three companies started around the
same time in china and eventually
alibaba
made a very big way so what i was doing
i was as an analyst covering amazon and
ebay both
out of silicon valley so for me shop
clues was the culmination
of best of both worlds on one hand india
has a very high cost of capital
and real estate is very expensive and
tails are really long
so i wanted to pick up a business which
is built on a marketplace principle
but on the other hand small mom and pop
sellers they are not as sophisticated
as a sim as a typical retailer in united
states
so i wanted to also give services very
similar to how amazon
give fulfillment by amazon for its
third-party business
so that is how so i combined best of
ebay best of amazon to create shop clues
and within six months we got half a
million sellers
who never had heard word called
e-commerce or what does it take to sell
online
uh and we will literally go one by one
to everyone sometime you know
sit at their small shop with our laptop
and create listing and train them
we created something called shop clues
university which had hundreds of hours
of
training programs to train them how you
know what did they take to sell online
so we had to do a lot of storm breaking
storm breaking work
really fundamental very most basic
things which you take for granted in us
every day
we had to actually literally educate
people for that also
uh and and that's how we started you
know like uh
uh anything you know i when i came to
india
i understood one thing that murphy law
will be applied on me and a
startup uh you know to the to raise to
the power of 10.
so anything which could go wrong would
go wrong any
anyone who can backstab us will backstab
anyone who can play any games will play
any games
so i assumed all of those so that i'm
better prepared and never get surprises
uh and uh you know but we had an
innovative model
we were way ahead we were five six years
ahead of our time
and eventually every large company
became marketplace but we were the first
one to start
and that that turned out to be quite
rewarding what is it like for you
what what are you how do you you know
looking back
you know what is it like today being
sunday parker well
knowing that you are you know one of the
one of the you know founding fathers of
of of india's tech ecosystem really
yeah so i i feel very blessed uh i feel
very blessed uh
michael about that clearly when i came
to the country
you know like if you if we may not
realize but united states for a young
entrepreneur
united states create a lot of local
heroes so i while growing up you can
take inspiration from mark zuckerberg to
steve jobs to bill gates to larry page
to sergey brin to elon musk you
you know i can name thousands of them
and united
united states has been producing local
heroes
at least for 70 80 years that was not
the case in india
here the local heroes are more of a
bollywood actors and cricketers
and politicians or a businessman which
were born with a silver spoon in their
mouth
so so you know coming here and honestly
becoming one of the local heroes who is
inspiring now others
uh it uh you know it absolutely feels uh
that you know
i i i can't account i can't stop
counting my blessings
uh and definitely you know uh people
sometimes call me father of marketplaces
sometime called internet visionary and
it's it's good
you know i think uh probably in the in
the beginning uh i would it felt like
you know
padding my own back and all but then i
accepted that you know
that you know whatever my market timing
and my own karma
result into two two very scalable and
good companies and i'm very proud of
that
so that that's where i am i also for
whatever it is worth
uh late last year i wrote a book called
uh
fall again rise again it's on my life
journey and
and the purpose of that was really
sharing my ordinary life
and my my simple middle class are
bringing and
inspiring others that if i can do it so
can you
and so so i did that it was a
best-selling book i did participate
in a program which is very similar to
shark tank which was ran by mtv for one
season
where i came as a judge and and every
day startup companies will come
live on a tv and pitch so i participated
in that
so i keep on making my contribution to
inspires other
i can't mentor and guide everyone but
wherever i can make a difference i try
to give back
that way wow i have too many things that
i want to ask and we only have five
minutes left i'm already upset
humble beginnings learning new
industries
i have i'm going to focus on two
questions now i know them
starting with the humble beginnings
millions billions around the world
are entering into a connected world this
is just
incredible and you know the
opportunities that people now have
whether it be education
or whether it be facilities or network
are just
we're still yet to really understand
them extracting from your personal
experiences
what what what are what are the
possibilities now and what can people
that don't necessarily
you know grow up in the most high-tech
or most innovative environment
what can they do see
uh michael uh you know since uh i would
say
right now we are living in the era where
the entry barriers for becoming an
entrepreneur
and pursuing your entrepreneurial dream
are so much more uh
so much more compelling and real with
low low entry barrier
from industrial revolution in 1750 until
now
i would say in the last 25 years there
has been a complete democratization
of entrepreneurship happening and it is
not and it is geography agnostic
it is background agnostic it is
education agnostic and to large extent
it is capital agnostic right so so long
as you carry a lot of passion lot of
energy
and and a mindset or maybe personality
of
not taking no for an answer i think you
will make it
right so i think uh i think the you know
uh
you know like one of the thing i i
always share people
that you know there was a gold rush in
california and in 1850
but there was one thing common among
everyone who found the gold
they were in california right so in my
view
independent of your background if you're
if you really want to pursue this dream
you go to you got to jump in the
bandwagon right i mean if this
you know in the last 250 years of modern
history of wealth creation
social transformation and
entrepreneurship this kind of era has
not come
with entry barriers have come down lot
of people can guide you
capital is easily available and and the
whole you know
every category is up for disruption and
innovation amazing and sandeep
you've done something that you know i
can only wish for myself in my wildest
dreams to be able to do to enter
a new market that doesn't exist yet not
do an evolution of it but do a
revolution for it
and be a you know a founding father of
this new concept
of something that is now impacting
millions of people and when you tell me
that
that you had those half a million people
that that previously just didn't have
existence online and all of a sudden
you're all of a sudden uh you know
you're
allowing them to change and transform
their whole business that's incredible
what did you learn that the typical
entrepreneur or even the typical
unicorn entrepreneur wouldn't have
because they didn't go through the same
experience what is that
what what did you learn from creating a
new a new place
see i think uh michael i feel first of
all
you know you know i came i came as a
student during first.com boom to united
states
uh and i was regretting to be paying
paying for expensive education and
studying
while everyone was creating our next
next uh next
hot startup in silicon valley uh right
uh and then when i graduated 9 11
happened.comboom.com
uh bust happened and i was just
babysitting my job
with the fear that i'll get fired any
day so i have seen
some of these things uh but one thing i
realized uh
early on is that if you do what you are
passionate about
then it's no longer a work that's the
single biggest thing i
i know it sounds cliche at times but
this has really helped me
my each subsequent job i realized i was
becoming closer and closer
to what i was truly in a very
uninhibited way
was passionate about and when i you know
i i became wall street analyst
out of the three jobs i did i was very
passionate about it when i became
entrepreneur
i realized that i would do this even if
i have to take money
even if i have to pay money for it
rather than you know making lots of
money
so my point is i think i think biggest
thing is passion second is you know when
you reach to a stage where you say that
the regret of not pursuing my vision
or my dream will be bigger than anything
i give up
right and then you basically you are
committed and you are you assume that
nothing is going to be straight line
anything which can go wrong will go
wrong right you also need to have an
emotional composure
that you can experience a new high and
sometime new law
and sometime you hire new law in a
matter of two hours
right i have seen a days where i have
celebrated the biggest achievement
and three or three three hour later i'm
finding a place to hide so that i can
cry
right so so you know you you need to
have all that mindset
uh and then you know of course there are
a lot of things you know everyone has a
different
style i'm little bit more data oriented
so i believe in you know if you cannot
measure you cannot control
so my personal style is that does not
matter what i do
i just measure everything so it's i
think it's a combination of all this
passion energy
undying desire and just you know and
just you know being very realistic
uh and and you know nothing is get
nothing gets created overnight
so one need to take little bit long-term
approach
it's hard for me to express how how
inspiring this is i'm considering taking
the first flight to new delhi and coming
to
to ask to be a right-hand man and just
follow you follow you and learn from
your movements
it's it's amazing but 20 minutes go by
very fast
and and i have a few questions that are
more fun they're not about what we
talked about
they're a little bit about you and i
want you to take me back to middle
school or high school
and what what fascinated you as a kid
what what was a subject that
really caught your attention in school
or outside of school
yeah so uh so so michael during my
school days uh you know
i was uh i was good in mathematics
probably from
day one uh i i did not like
actually science especially physics
chemistry and biology somehow i just
did not understand i i just adored uh
uh history i loved history and and as i
grew up i became
like i read a lot of word history so but
mathematics and word history
are something i absolutely loved but a
lot of
one thing i would say is that you know
until the age of 21
i was actually up almost like a
full-time sports uh
sports person i played two uh two sports
uh in school and high school while
growing up so i was academically
i would call at best uh maybe average my
mother will call me below average
but that's what i was academically and
spend most of my time playing but i was
always a builder and creator type of
what sports were they uh i played
cricket which is like uh you know
of course like a billion dollar people
are passionate about it and i play
badminton
um and i played both uh at actually at a
state uh you know at under 18
uh at a state level at as up as amazing
and uh who would be an inspiration of
yours or somebody
some role model throughout your career
that you that you got inspired by
real or fake yeah absolutely
absolutely so uh you know i think uh
from michael
uh like one thing i always realized that
you know whenever i read any biographies
or
autobiography i was particularly more
charged up that day
so you know but i had also opportunity
to work with bill gates because i worked
in microsoft in the corporate
headquarters
in redmond washington so bill gates jeb
bezos elon musk
steve jobs these would be these will be
the you know four names
where i think who have really made very
profound impact just you know i would
i would even look in the mirror and try
to mimic them emulate them
and and see how would they handle
different situations and without
realizing that that was also helping me
to become an entrepreneur in my own you
worked with bill gates
that's right i feel like i missed the
whole episode i i
i'm just shocked give me one experience
with bill gates that left an impression
on you i'm sorry that i'm running over
but i just have to know no no that's
okay
michael no so so you know look uh you
know when i worked at microsoft there
were like 74 000 full-time employees
probably hundred thousand contractors
so it is not common to work with him and
the day when i started my boss came and
he said you know bill gates or steve
baumer who was a ceo that time
would call you for some work and so i
happened to be in many meetings where
bill gates would be there
and one of the thing i noticed about him
is that you know
even thousands of people are present and
whatever they are presenting
he will process the information very
fast and he would be very logical
and and he kept very high standard for
himself and demanded nothing but the
best
right so these were the you know and the
thing which helped me is i often would
have hear him
not during the meetings but in general
also like three things which
he mentioned one is always go for a
large addressable opportunity
make sure technology is the center of
everything and make sure you have a high
gross margin category
and if you have these three things you
will create a world class company and
that later on in my as entrepreneurial
career i followed those three screens
always wow just
wow the last question and i'm so sad to
say this is the last question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
i would say michael i would say
you know passionate right i would say
maybe extremely extremely data driven
uh maybe almost like a when uh almost
like a nerd and geek when it comes to
data
consumption of data and seeking the data
uh that
uh and then what i would say maybe uh
uh out of the box thinker amazing
amazing sandeep
thank you so much this was just
wonderful
uh i'm absolutely michael thank you for
having me and i equally enjoy
i'm leaving with so much more energy
than i began with
and and that's amazing and that's why i
do this show i i'm
for these episodes thank you so much and
i really look forward to staying in
touch and
continuing to get many more advice and
experience from you so thank you
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
[Music]